お久しぶりです。
ゆまお：ありがとうございます。
ゆまお：結婚させて頂きました。
はじめ：おめでとうございます（ﾊﾟﾁﾊﾟﾁ）
はじめ：同い年の人が結婚するとまじで焦るんですけど
ゆまおの
お嫁さんとの間の
赤ちゃんに会えるという訳で
今回お邪魔させていただいております。
はじめ：ちょっと、、起きたら
よかったら、挨拶したいなと思っております。
フフフフ(´∀｀)（二人の笑い声）
はじめ：まさかなぁ・・・
はじめおじちゃんと呼ばれる日が来るとは・・・
はじめ：ちょっと
起きるまで
ゆっくりします。
ﾜｰｼｮｲ（はじめ何かを踏んずける）
ゆまお：あ、起きました起きました
はじめ：起きた？
ゆまお：起きましたね
（はじめｿﾜｿﾜ）
はじめ：うわぁ泣いてるよぉぉ・・
いやまじねぇ
同期・・・タメの人が
子供・・を持ったら
まじで
何か凄い気持ちになるからね？
ｴｰﾝ（赤子の泣き声）
はじめ：あら、あらららら
あらあらあら
うわぁ。。。
う、うう(/ω＼)
はじめ：こんにちはぁ(n*´ω`*n)
ゆまお：はじめましてーって
ゆまお：はじめまちてーは？
はじめ：かわいいなぁもう。。。
ゆまお：はじめおじちゃんだよ、はじめおじちゃん
はじめ：赤子ぉ
よぉ赤子ぉ！
ｴｰｰｰｰｰｰーーｰｰｰﾝ（赤子泣きだす）
はじめ：あ、やばいゆまさん
ごめんよぉ(´・ω・｀)
あぁ・・・ごめんねぇ・・ｲﾔｧ
俺嫌われてんのかな(´・ω・`)？
はじめ：ｱｧ・・・赤子赤子
赤子ぉ
俺も落ち着いたよ？
あ、ごめんね
ゆまお：トントントンって
はじめ：あぁ・・ごめんね😰
あ、ごめんね😰
ごめんね。。
ｱｧ・・大丈夫？
ゆまお：多分ねぇ、うんちしちゃってるからねぇ
はじめ：あぁ
ちょっと不快度指数が高め？
ゆまお：不快度指数が高め
はじめ：赤子どうした？
あぁ、、ｺﾞﾒﾝｺﾞﾒﾝｺﾞﾒﾝ
（骨の折れる音）
ｴｰｰｰｰｰｰｰｰｰﾝ（赤子の泣き声）
ゆまお：はじめおじちゃんがね、プレゼントをくれたんだよ
プレゼントくれた
ｴｰｰｰﾝ（赤子の泣き声）
はじめ：ｱﾊﾊ・・嫌だったの？
かわいい・・・やばい・・・
これはやばい
ｳｯｳｯｳﾌｪｰｰｰｰｰﾝ（赤子泣く）
ｳﾞｳﾞ、ｳﾞｳﾞﾌｳﾌｪｰｰﾝ（赤子の泣き声）
ﾌﾌﾊﾊ（笑うはじめ）
はじめ：ﾌｫﾌｫﾌｫﾌｫﾌｫﾌｫﾌｫﾌｪﾌｪﾌｪﾌｪﾌｪｳﾌｪｪﾌﾌｪｪ・・・・
ｱｳﾞｧｳﾞｧｳﾞｧｳﾞｧﾍﾞｳﾞｧﾍﾞ･・・･ｱ
ﾌﾌﾌﾊﾊ（はじめ、ゆまおの笑い声）
ﾌｯﾌｧｧﾊｧﾊﾊﾊﾊﾊﾊﾊﾌﾌﾊﾊﾌﾌﾊﾊﾌﾊ・・・・・ﾊｧ
はじめ：ジャングルジム買ってあげようかぁ？
ﾎｯﾎｯﾎｯ
おぉ？
んん？
あぁ・・え？笑ってるの？(〃∇〃)
笑ってる？？
ジャングルジム・・・・
ジャングルジム欲しい？
滑り台も買うか？
ｳﾎｫｯ
どうした？
うおぉ
指
お！
いち？
いちだって！
（ゆまおの笑い声）
はじめ：指だよぉ～
おお！
うおお！
うぉぉ・・うぉぉ・・・
はぁぁぁ・・・・・
グ・・駄目だ
胸がｷｭﾝてなる
胸がぁぁｷｭﾝてなるよ
はぁぁかわいいねぇぇぇぇ♡
ゆまお：あぇ～
はじめ：うわあ～
ゆまお：ひひぃ～😊
はじめ：おお～😊
はじめ：すっげぇご機嫌だなぁ
ゆまお：ご機嫌だねぇ
ゆまお：う～
赤子：う～
はじめ：おお～真似してるねぇ
ゆまお：いいですか？
これがミラーニューロンっていうやつですね
はじめ：え？なにそれ？
なんかそういうのやってんの？
はじめ：俺もミニャッーリューリョンやりたい
俺もミニャーリューリョンやる！
はじめ：アッハッハッハ
赤子：はじめん
はじめ：はっ！
だっ、誰だこの声は？！
はっ！？まさか！？
赤子：あたしだよ！A・KA・GO(^_-)-☆
はじめ：こいつ、俺の脳内に直接・・・！
赤子：今日は来てくれてありがとう
はじめ：ﾊｯ！笑ってる・・
かわいい・・ありがとうこちらこそ！
赤子：あたしいつでも待ってるから
また遊びに来てねぇ
はじめ：赤子にそんなこと言われるなんて感激(´；ω；`)
赤子：次来るときは
ミルク６０ℓと替えのおむつ６１０枚を準備してきなさ～い
はじめ：分かりました。
貴方のためなら喜んで！！！
赤子：あとはよだれかけを１７００枚とベビーカー９２００台
あとはしばらくのあたしの生活費１０年分を
指定した口座に振り込んでおきなさい
はじめ：分かりました。直ちに。
はじめ：あとはおしゃぶりも赤子のために
２万個ほど準備しておきますね(''◇'')ゞ
赤子：あー、それはいらねーわ
（エンディング曲）
はじめ：ねぇもうほんとなんなん
かわいいねぇ
おっと！
それは俺の...くｔ((